To many climbers, mountaineers, and general
fans of low oxygen environments, summiting
Mount Everest represent the literal peak of
physical achievement.
But while an impressive feat for a human,
it turns out vultures can happily survive
exposed to altitudes of 40,000 ft or 12,200
meters above sea level and, indeed, have been
seen flying around at this height.
(For reference, this is about 11,000 ft or
3,350 meters above the peak of Everest.)
Meanwhile tardigrades laugh in the face of
the conditions on Everest, able to survive
even nakedly exposed to outer space for quite
some time with no ill effects.
(Although, note: humans can actually survive
exposed to the near vacuum of space for about
90 seconds without long term damage, but we
have nothing on the tardigrade for durability
in just about any environment.)
And let’s not even talk about microbes…
In the end, there are creatures that can outdo
even the best of humans at pretty much any
physically intensive task we feel like setting
our minds to, no matter how hard we train
and how good our genetics.
But you know what no other known living thing
can do?
Use their minds to create machinery to do
an otherwise extremely arduous and dangerous
task in about a half an hour, all while kicking
back in a very comfy chair.
And that’s exactly what French fighter pilot
Didier Delsalle did when he conquered Everest
in a product of human ingenuity- the Eurocopter
Ecureuil AS350 B3 helicopter.
Humans 1, Animal Kingdom 0.
Although Delsalle is the first and so far
only person in history to land a helicopter
on the summit of the world’s highest peak,
likeminded daredevils and pilots have been
trying to do exactly that since at least the
early 1970s.
One of the most notable of these individuals
is Jean Boulet who still holds the record
for highest altitude reached by a helicopter
at 40,820 ft (12,442 meters), at which point
his engine died, though he did manage to land
safely.
(Yes, contrary to popular belief, helicopters
don’t just drop like a rock when the engine
dies, and they are relatively safe in this
condition.
In fact, you have a better chance of surviving
in a helicopter when the engine fails than
you do in an airplane where the same happens.)
Like Boulet before him, Delsalle broached
the subject of landing a helicopter on Everest
with the company he flew helicopters for (in
this case Eurocopter) and was similarly stonewalled
by killjoy executives who didn’t want to
deal with the negative PR if he crashed.
Delsalle didn’t let the subject drop and
repeatedly badgered higher ups within the
company, using the better-than-expected results
from the test of a new engine in 2004 to convince
Eurocopter that landing their Ecureuil AS350
B3 helicopter on Everest was entirely possible.
The company executives finally relented and
gave Delsalle some time (and a helicopter)
to test his hypothesis.
After all, while a failed attempt would create
a lot of negative press, a successful one
would be a fantastic marketing move, with
their helicopter doing something no other
had ever done.
Or as Delsalle himself would state,
The idea was to prove to our customers all
the margins they have while they’re using
the helicopter in the normal certified envelope,
compared to what the helicopter is capable
of during the flight test.
Delsalle then took the helicopter and flew
it to 29,500 feet, about 6,500 feet above
the helicopter’s listed maximum operating
altitude and around 500 feet higher than the
peak of Everest.
No problem.
After a number of additional tests proved
that the helicopter would in theory have no
trouble landing on Everest’s peak, Delsalle
and his trusty helicopter headed to Nepal.
Once there, while conducting recon on the
mountain, Delsalle cemented his reputation
as an all round awesome guy by taking the
time to rescue two stranded Japanese climbers.
When he wasn’t saving lives, he could be
found jogging around the hanger in an attempt
to drop every gram possible from his body
weight.
Likewise, he lightened the helicopter slightly
be removing the passenger seats- the point
of all this was to be able to extend flight
time slightly.
However, as part of the purpose of this publicity
stunt was to show off what the Ecureuil AS350
B3 could do, other than this marginal lightening
of its load, no other modifications were made.
And so it was that on the morning of May 14,
2005, Delsalle slipped on two pairs of thermal
underwear under his flight suit and took off.
As for his choice of under attire, this was
needed as he flew the entire distance with
his window open…
He did this rather than keep things more climate
controlled as he was concerned his windows
would have iced up in the -31 F (-35 C) temperatures
had he not kept the temperatures equalized
on both sides of the glass.
As for the ascent, this was not quite as easy
as simply rising to the necessary altitude-
Delsalle had to deal with some pretty remarkable
up and down drafts, which is one of the reasons
even today helicopter rescues at extreme altitudes
on Everest are a rarity.
As he stated,
On one side of the mountain, on the updraft
side, I wasn’t able to approach the mountain
because even taking out all of the power of
the aircraft, I was still climbing.
But of course on the other side you had the
downdraft side, and on this side even with
maybe 60 knots on the airspeed indicator I
was going backward . . . and the helicopter
at full power was not powerful enough to counteract
that.
“Landing”, or more aptly touching down,
also wasn’t an easy task.
When you reach the summit you reach the updraft
point, and of course the updraft winds have
enough force to throw you away as soon as
you put the collective down.
I had to stick my skids on the summit and
push into the mountain to stay on the summit.
Another big problem there is that you have
no visual of the summit, and you have no specific
cues, because you are on the highest point.
You are in free air in fact, and you have
to try to find where is the summit exactly.
After keeping the skids pressed against the
tiny area of land that is the summit for 3
minutes and 50 seconds, Delsalle decided it
was time to go, which turned out to be quite
simple thanks to the strong updraft: “I
had just to pull a little bit on the collective
and I went to flying very easily.”
Amusingly, nobody climbing the mountain that
day had any idea that Delsalle was planning
on doing this and reports later flooded in
to Nepalese authorities about a random helicopter
seen flying around the summit.
But here’s the best part- when Delsalle
landed and went to check the recordings documenting
his amazing accomplishment, the computer showed
zero files where the recordings should have
been.
Yes, he had no hard evidence he had actually
done this, invalidating his record attempt.
Rather than waiting to see if the data could
be recovered (and presumably not wanting to
endure doubters for any longer than absolutely
necessary), Delsalle instead opted to just
do it all over again the very next day- this
time making sure the recording equipment was
functioning.
(It should also be noted here that some of
the urgency was because no one was summiting
on the day in question, but were after.
For safety reasons, he could not attempt the
touch down if anyone was climbing around the
summit.)
If at this point you’re now doubting his
May 14th story actually happened, we should
probably mention that they were later able
to recover the first day’s logs and video,
proving he had done what he said.
Of course, doubters will persist no matter
if you slap them in the face with video evidence,
data logs, several Everest climber accounts
of spotting the helicopter flying around the
summit, his helicopter skid marks that for
a time existed in the snow at that hallowed
peak, etc.
But as for the Federation Aeronautique Internationale
and a few other such official bodies, as his
evidence of the two touch downs on the summit
was incontrovertible, they officially ratified
his remarkable achievement, much to the chagrin
of many an Everest climber, who almost universally
lamented the accomplishment owing to the supposed
ease at which summiting the mountain was achieved.
But here again, we feel compelled to point
out that humans compiling the knowledge and
expertise needed to design/construct a machine
that was then extremely skillfully landed
on this hallowed, tiny patch of snow covered
land isn’t actually easy at all when you
think about it.
(And don’t even get us started on what it
took to compile the knowledge and expertise
to make the tools that made the parts for
the machine in question… or the tools that
made the parts for the more advanced tools,
such as mind boggling complex computers used
along the whole process…)
One might even posit that summiting Everest
in the more traditional way is orders of magnitude
easier than the way Delsalle did it, when
looking at the big picture.